halima nakai is the reigning 800 meters
world champion
and she's only the second ugandan woman
to win a gold medal
at the world athletics championships
after dokas inzikuru
15 years ago in finland nakai has
written her own story in a country known
to produce long-distance runners people
used to think that maybe
every in africa we can't have maybe
champions in middle distance
especially even uganda was we had no
champion middle distance
a 19th plus finish at the 2017 world
athletics championships in london
did not deter her determination to
succeed
she stayed focused to finish fourth at
the 2018
african athletics championships in
nigeria
in front of how is south africa's casta
cement
the two-time olympic champion has been
banned from running in the 800 meters
for refusing to take medication to
control her naturally occurring
testosterone
levels it was so amazing competing with
caster because she was a good friend and
always
up now she's a good friend so i loved it
and
she kept on motivating us telling us
that things are possible
because i used to maybe sometimes you
can ask her how can i become a great
middle distance runner like you it's a
matter of training
semenya's absence from the track has
massively changed
the 800 meters landscape for nakai this
was a life-changing opportunity and in
doha
at the wild athletics championships she
grabbed it with both her hands
and the rest is history with the 2020
olympics postponed to next summer
nakai dreams of a medal in tokyo
my main target is to be like the
greatest athletes those ones who are
have become champions and have
maintained it
semenya continues to be banned from
competing
in international events and her absence
has created a platform
for new faces to emerge what's becoming
the new number for middle distance
running at international events asha kam
gesha
al jazeera kampala uganda